Let's consider a really
simplified version of
the example we just talked about.
We generated a forest model in order
to predict the unknown data from
the employees who did not respond.
Let's apply this model to a particular
employee who is 1.5 miles away from work
to illustrate how
the forest model will work.
Remember the trees here are simplified
to demonstrate the concept.
For the first tree, a random
sample of the data is taken, and
a tree is created from it.
Here's the tree.
Since the employee we are trying
to predict lives 1.5 miles away,
this tree would predict that she has
a 50% chance of driving to work, 30%
chance of taking public transportation,
and a 20% chance of walking or biking.
Now another tree is generated
from a different random sample.
Here's that tree.
In this tree our employees predicted to
have a 20% chance of driving, 30% chance
of using public transportation, and
a 50% chance of walking or biking.
A third tree is generated from
a different random sample.
Here is that tree now.
In this tree, our employee is predicted
to have a 30% chance of driving,
20% chance of using public transit,
and a 50% chance of walking or biking.
In a forest model, hundreds of
trees like this would be created,
and then the results of each would
be averaged to make a prediction.
Let's average based off these
three trees to make a prediction.
So driving is 50% + 20% + 30% / 3, so
it's 33% likely to be driving.
The public transit was 30%, 30%,
and 20% when you divide that by 3,
that's 27% likely to be
public transportation.
And then walking and
biking had a 20%, 50%, and
a 50% chance divided by 3,
which equals 40%.
So you can see that if we had
only used the first tree,
that because of overfitting,
it may have had a very different
prediction than the forest model.
It would have predicted most
likely our employee drove.
But using a forest technique,
it predicted that she most
likely walked or biked.